[Musique]
voir des enfants bonsoir chers petits
zone où est ton échelle nounours je l'en
ai pas besoin pas trop comment qui ne
descendent pas chez nicolas et
pimprenelle ce soir non patron ils ont
été trop méchant avec moi hier soir je
ne dirais pas les voir comme tu veux
nounours mais écoute il ya un enfant qui
pleure en mai c'est vrai on dira nicolas
au jeté sans jeter saut ce petit nicolas
j'élève tellement europe papa
[Musique]
makuta aux non maman ne va pas être
contente il faut toujours faire plaisir
à sa maman moi quand j'étais petit
attends je vais te dire ce que je
faisais quand j'étais petit
[Musique]
josu vignon
quand je te punit
je
tous vivent
ban
petit pas boucherie
e
[Musique]
vent
il ya plus de
prends ma peau
on hulu
moi j'aurais pour d'un
chic ou
maman chevaux
est vite rejoint
jusqu'à la berge bruit
[Musique]
qu'on
s'était mieux
monde
rémy en
bas
mon doigt
plusieurs avec moi
ou jaune
raymonde heures
jeux
noynoy astruit sûrs au camp
bauchau vous le
savoir lire
et écrire
majeur et milan
tout est à la barre
[Musique]
pendant ce temps leur
je l'appelle à vue
longtemps
mais je n'oublie pas
que ma maman
a toujours été fier de moi
en
oui il faudrait m'ont
bien
conduit heureux c'est faire plaisir
à sa fille
hautmont
[Musique]
cela aussi fait plaisir à votre maman
il faut toujours être très gentil avec
sa maman
[Musique]
où
en route mon cher nounours
j'espère que tous les enfants ont bien
manger leur soupe ce soir pour faire
plaisir à leur maman ait eu un loup
l'ours bonne nuit fait pour eux
[Musique]